the search for the living has ended in
Northwest Syria it's now about removing
the bodies trapped under the hundreds of
buildings that collapsed following the
earthquakes that hit turkey and Syria on
Monday those who responded to the human
tragedy say the world failed the people
in the opposition controlled Enclave the
civil defense also known as white
helmets said people died because
repeated requests for rescue support
teams and heavy machinery never came I
have been deeply affected by the voices
we heard from under the rubble they were
crying for help in one instance we
worked for four hours before we're able
to reach a man but it was too late he
died destruction and Devastation are not
only in the opposition-held areas in the
North
but in heavily populated
government-health cities like Aleppo
Hama and Latakia as well the United
Nations estimates more than 5 million
people are now homeless
we evacuated people from all the
buildings that we deemed dangerous
shelters have begun receiving people
it's a new wave of displacement already
there are nearly 7 million syrians who
have been displaced in their own country
due to the war that began more than a
decade ago many are in the north where 4
million depended on Aid before the
earthquake destroyed more lives on
Friday the Syrian government said it
will allow Aid to reach areas outside
its control in what appeared to be a
concession linked to a deal that
involved waving some sanctions for Quake
relief but so far it hasn't happened the
state's opponents have long feared the
consequences of so-called cross-line
deliveries the opposition in Northwest
Syria is afraid of receiving cross and
aid for many reasons but primarily
they're afraid of their regime
holding that Lifeline against them using
it in the future to coerce them into
providing political concessions Aid has
started to come in from the Babel Hawa
border with turkey the only Crossing
authorized by the UN for eight
deliveries the opposition says the
International Community should ignore
objections from Damascus and use more
Crossings to ensure the constant flow of
relief supplies already the world food
program says it's running out of stocks
in the opposition Enclave where more
than 90 percent of people relied on Aid
before the latest disaster al-shazira